ukraine says its capital has suffered
horrific rocket strikes overnight
russian troops are moving closer to kiev
on the second full day of this attack
it has been a night of unrest for
thousands of ukrainians as missiles
struck the city residential buildings on
the outskirts were hit and firefighters
are still putting out the flames we
understand the ukrainian army says
russia fired on civilian areas but its
air defense systems have repelled
attacks
ukrainians in the capital waking up to
that sound the sound of sirens this
morning their president vladimir
zelinski is warning of what he calls
enemy sabotage groups already in kiev in
an early morning address zielinski said
he's a target but dismissed rumors that
he has fled the capital
information
there's information that enemy sabotage
groups have entered kiev so i ask the
people of kiev be careful respect the
curfew rules i am staying in the
government quarter together with all
those who are needed for the central
government to work
according to the information we have the
enemy has designated me as target number
one my family is tuck number two they
want to destroy ukraine politically by
destroying the head of state
just after seven hours gmt that's nine
am local time in kiev andrew simmons is
our correspondent there andrew just take
us through what's been going on
overnight there
horrific horrendous
all adjectives that are accurate in
what's been happening here overnight
a litany of air strikes there was also a
one success for the ukrainian defense
in that they shot down one of the
fighter jets um fighter bomber should i
say and that unfortunately crashed down
into a civilian area unknown number of
casualties but at least one dead
there has
i'm sad to report uh been a large number
of air raids uh since uh dawn um we've
had on three occasions uh the air raid
sirens going off uh and a civilian area
was struck by one of those uh
one of those air raids uh we're assured
uh sadly we don't know um the level of
impact in terms of civilian loss uh
we're also hearing now and this is very
new um an unconfirmed report that
ukraine has fired uh ballistic missiles
at um milorovo
airport that's a military airfield
near rostov
in russia proper that's over the border
so this is escalating in every respect
not just in the air but on the ground as
well armoured columns all heading
towards the city the latest report
is about 30 kilometers away with one
column coming
coming down southwards
to
this city
there has been some successes on the
ground um by the ukrainians they've
repelled they've counter-attacked at
hostamell which is an airfield about 15
kilometers away from the capital
that airfield had been attacked on
thursday by helicopter gunships russian
helicopter gunships um really uh causing
a lot of damage not to the runway but
taking out uh the the whole airfield to
allow reportedly uh paratroopers to land
in in large troop carrying aircraft uh
but that is uh that has not come to
fruition that though we are we
understand that whatever happened those
paratroopers didn't arrive but what did
happen was that the ukrainians launched
a counter-attack and took the airfield
back that's the latest there
and in terms of these armoured columns
the ukrainians seem to be having some
success uh with their new weaponry their
missile launches and their uh apparently
did repel uh one attack um
which was uh um coming down from the uh
belarus border that's something like 40
50 kilometers away from that border they
came up against very fierce resistance
and what we're also hearing is that uh
ukrainian special forces
are blowing up bridges in key points uh
they're not giving the details of all of
them for obvious reasons but they are
attacking bridges they're blowing them
up in order to actually bring
the advancing ground forces to a halt
but it's an overwhelming in the words of
of the press office for the military
they're using the worm oh the word
overwhelming force uh being used by the
enemies so this is colossal it's uh
scenes that haven't been witnessed since
the second world war
and now sadly we're getting civilians
involved this is a look back at the past
24 hours
[Music]
the russian invasion was launched with
terrifying speed and against a wide
range of targets right across the
country
the long military buildup around
ukraine's borders finally unleashed by
order of the kremlin
helicopter gunships fighter jets
missiles tanks convoys of armored
vehicles are all involved in what russia
calls a military operation
for the moment the targets appear to be
specific and strategic they include
ukraine's airfields and military bases
this video from malitopol in southern
ukraine appears to show the destruction
of the city's airfield
the shrapnel and shells are also
reported to have landed in civilian
areas
including the capital kiev
until the very last moment i didn't
believe it would happen i thought it
might just involve donetsk and luhansk
but i didn't ever think it would involve
kiev
most likely war has now begun everyone
is leaving everywhere is shut
i hate the country that started this war
i speak as a mother and as a ukrainian
and i call on the whole world to help us
and stop this aggressor
ukraine's government declared martial
law
[Music]
i had a conversation with u.s president
joe biden the u.s is starting to gather
international support
today we need you each of you to be calm
if possible stay at home please we are
working the army is working the entire
security and defense sector of ukraine
is working
the russian military offensive follows a
carefully choreographed strategy
of russia's president vladimir putin
he unilaterally recognized two
separatist regions in eastern ukraine as
independent of kiev and then sent
russian soldiers in under the pretext of
being peacekeepers
the battle for luhansk and donetsk in
eastern ukraine has been going on since
2014
with more than 14 000 people killed in
fighting between the russian-backed
separatists and the ukrainian
army now what putin calls peacekeepers
are on the attack and the russian leader
is warning ukrainian soldiers not to
resist
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history we are ready for
any outcome the russian invasion began
despite last-ditch appeals from members
of the united nations security council
to ease tension
ukraine's ambassador to the un demanded
his russian counterpart step down as
chairman call putin call lavrov
to stop aggression
there is no purgatory for war criminals
they go straight to hell ambassador
as news of the invasion spread in
ukraine's capital kiev main highways out
of the city quickly became gridlocked
with traffic
there's a mood of desperation developing
now many people just jumping into their
cars getting their families together and
heading on the road trying to get to
poland
but the main auto routes are all jammed
there are so many people trying to do
the same thing others are going
underground taking shelter
others have been flocking to the
supermarkets and frantically stocking up
on essential items
this was the scene in kramatorsk in the
east of ukraine as shoppers grabbed what
they could to fill their cupboards the
ukrainian army and air force are putting
up a fight and resisting the russian
attack
this video from the defense ministry
said to show a russian helicopter shot
down by ukrainian forces near kiev
but there will be no reinforcements from
nato
and the odds look heavily stacked
against ukraine's forces
so andrew
day two of this invasion how's the
civilian population
bearing up under what must be incredible
pressure
yes so that is the right term peter
that's it's just a horrendous for them
um
many
thousands we think uh managed to get
away they took an immediate decision
before dawn uh
the beginning of the airstrikes and the
ground force invasion uh they got away
and they got into poland and we've been
seeing uh pictures of them all crossing
the border and going through the process
with uh with their visas but uh the
majority of them um had well they were
dazed and confused in some places but
then they had to take shelter
and and right now this friday well
it's horrendous for them they're all
basically getting into positions where
they can get safe when the air raid
sirens go off but the air raid sirens
sometimes don't give a lot of warning i
mean that's the nature of war
and you don't have time to get into a
place
of safety there are four main metro
stations where people are basically
living now
there's real anger in the air
people are really furious uh there's a
the hatred for vladimir putin is is
palpable um and
furthermore
there are a number of uh
places in the city
where you can get any gun of your choice
particularly in ak-47 to defend yourself
and that is the policy of the presidency
vladimir uh zielinski is
of a mood where he wants everyone to
fight he's stepped up the mobilization
know that we're it's reported that no
males of fighting ages are allowed to
get out now he wants everyone
hunkered down and and
trying to avoid the the the air raids
anyone fit enough should be fighting
because that's what they're ready for
every place of shelter is awash with
rumors and also hatred for vladimir
putin as i was saying and what we're
going to find is
when these forces and i say when it's
not if really it does look like when the
russian forces reach the capital
there is likely to be fierce resistance
and we're getting warnings also that
there are undercover
russian agents heavily armed in the city
um that is uh the presidency say that
that is the case be careful watch out if
you're out on the streets it's utterly
well there's a few cars driving around
and they're invariably driving around at
high speed uh responding to various
reports of
of activity uh but the as i say
we can't show you pictures we can't get
there right now but the hospitals are
struggling with the level of casualties
right now and also to bring you up to
date with what vladimir zielinski has
been saying uh his latest figure this
morning was 137
dead and and of those 10 officers we're
talking about losses in the field we're
talking about losses of of soldiers uh
who will all posthumously be given um
medals of honor uh however the civilian
numbers of casualties is not clear i
think you could almost say from what
we're hearing that that figure has gone
up quite quite considerably and possibly
nearer 200 when you're hearing about all
the reports we're getting of these these
attacks but um the overall mood to
answer the question in in a sentence is
one of
an absolutely horrendous fear of what's
going to happen next
andrew thank you very much stay close
andrew simmons our correspondent there
live for us in the ukrainian capital
kiev well here's a snapshot of what's
happening on the ground as far as we can
tell you russian forces have attacked
areas across ukraine multiple cities are
under fire this is the approximate
location of those strikes russian troops
have moved in by land air and sea to the
east from russia south from crimea and
north from bella the bella russian side
there have also been naval attacks from
the sea of azov hoda abdel himi joins us
live now from kramertorsk in eastern
ukraine hoda what's the latest that's
been going on on the ground there
overnight
well actually as that lady in the report
from andrews just said
everyone was expecting that the big push
the beginning of this world would have
started here in the east with all these
uh more than a hundred thousand russian
troops just across the border well none
of that happened yes there is sporadic
shelling uh on along the front line
between the ukrainian army and the uh
separatists uh the separatists have
tried a push in
lugan's uh region region sort of north
east from where i'm standing
they managed to go across in a point
called chestya but then the ukrainian
took that back so there hasn't been any
major movement along that line we are
hearing now that in the south
in the vicinity of marijuana obviously
there there has been much more activity
for the last 24 hours there has been a
lot of attacks the russians trying to
put a lot of pressure on the ukrainians
in the area and we are we are hearing
that they might be advancing towards
burjansk which is
a city just on the coast on the along
the as of sea uh but we still don't i
still not confirmed how far they have
been but what is clear is that
at the moment from what we have seen
unfolding in the last uh 24 to 36 hours
is that
russia by attacking kiev by attacking
kharkev is trying
to put pressure there
to then have the the
ukrainian army units that are posted
here in the east that are
supposed to be are reputed to be the
strongest and the better equipped to
capitulate at the moment they are
standing strong and there is no major
push because the rest the separatists
can't do it alone if they were to push
they need the russians with them to be
able to push because at the end of the
day the ukrainian army is a regular army
it's strong it's been there for the last
eight years it's well entrenched and
it's well equipped i'm just wondering if
we can pull up the map hotter so we can
show the viewers exactly where you are
because kramatorsk is kind of directly
due north of mariopol down there which
is towards crimea so it's in that
corridor area
from
eastern ukraine and where you are hoda
is one of those areas one of those towns
that's kind of exposed in a way because
it's kind of isolated it's not close to
kiev it's close
to
western central russia so that must be
an awareness that the people have there
what are they saying the people of the
city
because we had four months of a build up
of russian military but when it came
when it came to it this time yesterday
it still clearly came as a surprise
it did come up as a surprise and i just
to for our viewers to understand kramer
taurus is a major commercial hub in this
area it's one of the main cities and
it's only a 10-minute drive from
slavians back in 2014 and 15 well the
separatists had pushed all the way to
slavians that's one of the first moves
they had done it's a symbolic city for
them and they had taken over the city
council there they have
surrounded it with rubber tires and
that's where you also had their russian
advisors based so many people expected
that that would be a push from the
separatists this side now you have
pro-russian people here and all over uh
the regions of don yes and
in some places it's 50-50 in some places
you have a majority of pro-russian
opinions very interesting i was talking
this morning to a young man who is from
kamatos who is pro-russian whose friends
are pro-russian well he said i would
like to have better relations with
moscow i would like that ukraine and
russia be on on much better terms he's
not necessarily for the separatists
because there is a sort of
memory there of the when the separatists
were ruling in this city and in this
area and they are not good memories but
he said with all what's unfolding in
kiev well he doesn't agree with that
anymore he said to me that his friends
don't agree with that anymore that
russia has gone way too far and that is
what i think vladimir putin is up
against because he's keeping this part
of the country the one where he has the
most support at peace at the moment yes
there has been sporadic bombings yes he
has targeted some bases and some
military units especially away from the
front line here in kramatos at four
o'clock in the morning uh yesterday when
it started in kiev there were loud
explosions but if you continue if this
continues well people here are going to
be alienated because the pictures are
circulating everywhere what is unfolding
in kiev is shocking people here and i
think vladimir putin would lose a lot of
support as long as what's go unfolding
in kiev in libya and other places
continues to happen now are they
expecting a war here are they expecting
the push to happen here yes because the
end game is obviously to take the entire
dones
against region because what that's what
the separatists want that's what they
have written in the constitution and
that's what they see as their historic
land so it is a very interesting
situation vladimir putin is saying that
he is protecting the ethnic russians in
this part of the country he is
protecting the russian speakers in this
cult of the country where he is
alienating some of them at the moment
and i think with more
with the hours to pass and more uh you
know fighting going across and what
what's unfolding in cave he might lose
that support oh thank you very much
in eastern ukraine
charles stratford south of there is just
outside mario paul on thursday he did
see a convoy of tanks some of them
flying ukrainian flags
i'm close to a checkpoint on the
outskirts of mariota
military vehicles behind me
heading down the road heading west
i don't know whether you can see
quite yet on the other side of the road
there is a
convoy of tanks appearing
in the last 10 15 minutes or so we've
heard the distinctive thud
of what sound to be
grad missiles being used
these are these missiles that are
just leaving that so you can see the
tanks
coming out
heading into marriott
but as i say in the last
few minutes we've heard the distinctive
sounds of grand missiles being used
in the
not too far distance
now
across the field here
there are ukrainian military
installations that we understand
were hit earlier
billowing smoke coming from them
another couple of tanks
interestingly that tank being
being towed
to suggest it may well have been hit
but uh
yeah also increasingly we've seen more
and more people leaving from this
checkpoint this checkpoint the road
going down
towards the west towards cities like
berdansk on the as of sea
um as well as dinipro in the north north
west
and interestingly we have been speaking
to a source in the navy in around
verdansk who says that earlier today
naval forces off the coast of the azov
sea off the coast of bredansk
came under fire from russian navy
russian naval vessels
forcing them back to base
charles stratford there near mario paul
let's bring in fabrice pottier he's a
chief strategy officer at the political
consultants rasmussen global he's also
formerly a director of policy planning
at nato he's joining us from santander
in spain fabrice pottery ben wallace the
uk defense secretary just saying on
domestic british television that the
russian forces have not achieved yet
what they wanted to achieve on day one
but he's also saying in his opinion
russia wants to take all of ukraine is
he right
well he probably has more uh
intelligence uh than than me but it
looks like indeed uh
putin decided to go for for clearly for
kiev
so it's a behaving strategy that we are
watching here
and yes uh the russian forces are not
probably made as quickly progress as
they expected
but if you look at the numbers if you
look at the equipment uh and the will
i think it's pretty uh pretty obvious
that the russian forces will prevail at
some point also given the kind of
technology and military gear that uh the
for the russian forces have like jamming
and any television surveillance and
reconnaissance the the ukrainian army is
obviously much stronger than it was
eight years ago
better train better equipped but it's
still kind of an asymmetric fight here
so i have to say that yes it looks like
if it's the whole of ukraine start and
especially for kiev and then i think
what putin wants to do is to to impose
the terms uh he wants probably to have a
regime that is seen as sympathetic to to
his uh twisted vision of this greater
russia and he probably wants to
consolidate some kind of territory uh
with some language going from the
eastern dombas all the way to odessa
so i think this is what we are watching
now and the sad truth is is the west is
just uh standing by and watching because
sanctions are important unity token
important but now we're in a sequence of
military confrontation and against that
you can only respond by force
and we are not at all managing this
escalation uh putin has the hand on the
escalation and is keeping the strategic
advantage if day one the first 24 hours
has not gone in the desired direction as
far as the russians are concerned do
they now have to start rethinking their
strategy because we have to engage with
the growing reality don't we which is
there was a perception
that the front line was where eastern
ukraine meets south central russia but
there are other front lines up north in
ukraine where it abuts bella russia that
there is a front line there and also
coming from the south
from the sea in and around about crimea
it seems but again i'm not a tactical
specialist and i don't have as much
intelligence as government officials but
it seems that the russian forces they're
trying to encircle the strongest and
best ukrainian forces that are deployed
on the uh so-called contact line
in order to basically
be uh put them in front of a dilemma you
fight to death or you just have to give
up
so it seems that they are trying to
encircle and avoid
the core of the ukrainian forces and
going for careful as quickly as possible
in order to have basically a political
capitulation
i think this is really what we're
watching now
when you use the word capitulation there
fabrice uh is that what mr putin wants
to go for would he
back off if he got capitulation
surrender let's come up with another
word that means the same thing because
he could have done what he's doing just
now at any point
over the past eight years but he's
chosen to do it
after four months of warning the world i
am building up my supply my stock of my
fighting machine across the border from
eastern ukraine
yes i i i mean i think it's pretty clear
that he wants a change of regime
and a regime that should be in his view
sympathetic to russia's interests
starting with obviously turning down uh
the nato and the eu membership path uh
claiming some kind of neutrality or
finland uh uh uh position uh so i think
this is one one of his goals
um but zelensky is going to put on the
fight and and obviously we should not
fault that because this is the most
important element of what is happening
you have more than 40 million ukrainian
people who feel ukrainian uh who don't
want necessary to be part of russia and
and and therefore putin knows very well
as an occupying power russia will face a
growing cost of of this operation so
he's trying to go for for a quick
operation in order to quickly impose his
terms and probably after i get withdraw
and custodizate his presidents in in
more friendly territory uh so this is
this is the the game we're in but
zelensky also knows very well that of
course there can be a people resistance
and i think this is what he's calling on
but this will be a at a dramatic cause
for for ukraine
people population and the ukrainian
economy so this is this is a very uh
dire situation and it is sad to see that
the west is obviously claiming to put
together some significant sanctions and
he's coming up with important statement
of unity and a resolve but at the end
the west is not going to put a single
nato soldier on ukrainian soul and this
is what could make
the only difference right now